[Music]
two objects cannot occupy the same point
in
Space the same moment in
time the corner race is at
you you have perhaps a crisis of
identity am I Sportsman
[Music]
or a
competitor if you get into one of my
[Music]
cars you get into
win
[Music]
slow and
so you're going
broke how you spend more than you make
so what do I do win the
Mia or you are out of
business this is a gun pointed at her
head you should assigned me control of
your St I have to have all the cards in
my hand well half the cards are in my
hand all of us are
Racers so deadly
passion our terrible Joy no wonder if we
need be back how can I stay
W eventually is looking for a
scapegoat then here I
am you were supposed to save him you
promised me he wouldn't die the father
deluded
himself
two objects cannot occupy the same point
in
space at the same moment in
time when
so go beat the hell out of
them